so in the last video I was talking about
various functions of money you know the
first was that it's a medium of exchange
if you want to trade for things
typically you give someone money and
they give you the thing rather than
trying to barter trading apples for
oranges or horses for legal services or
things like this the second is that it's
a store of value if you hold on to your
money its value isn't just going to
evaporate whereas if you hold on to you
know a bunch of apples as they rot and
degrade away they're no longer valuable
and the third is that it's a unit of
value it's a way that we assign a number
to items to say how valuable is this you
know that something that's a hundred
dollars is about twice as valuable as
something that's fifty dollars and
having this sort of number system for
value makes it a lot easier to compare
different goods and what I want to do in
this video is talk about a circumstance
where these functions of money break
down and what I'm thinking of is the
case of hyperinflation hyper inflation
now inflation means that prices are
increasing so if you you know look at a
the price of a carton of milk and let's
say it's one dollar one day it would be
if it increases later on so maybe it's a
dollar twenty cents and if the prices of
all goods as a whole in the economy tend
to be increasing you know it's not just
milk is getting rarer or something like
that it's it's called inflation and
hyperinflation is basically a case where
this is just happening really really
quickly so Sal has some videos talking
about inflation itself and the root
causes and I'm not going to go into that
here in this case all you need to know
is the idea that prices increase really
really quickly and just to give give an
example there's been lots throughout
history and this isn't necessarily the
starkest example but it'll be
interesting to us in terms of what the
ultimate solution was Brazil in the
1980s and early 1990s
so 1980s and a little bit into the early
1990s was undergoing very fast inflation
and to give a feel for the kind of rates
we're talking about at its peak it was
around 80 percent eighty percent per
month and what this means is that every
month the prices of general Goods you
know a carton of milk or a chair or the
price of land things like that would
generally get multiplied by a factor of
1.8 now if you compound this over a full
year and every month it's increasing by
1.8 so you multiply it in twelve
different times
this is actually an increase by more
than a factor of a thousand so that
would mean if you have something that
costs a hundred dollars one day it's
going to cost after a year if inflation
increases at this rate a hundred
thousand dollars so the annual inflation
rate the percentage per year would
actually be one hundred thousand percent
per year now there have been inflation
rates in history faster than this but
this is still really insane and just to
get our minds around what it might feel
like to be in an economy like this let's
just imagine a super simplified economy
where you have only four different
people so we'll have four different
people here and let's say I don't know
let's name these guys like person a
person B person C and person D I guess I
give should you give person D some eyes
and let's say it's the case that the way
that this economy works is that a buys
all of his things from B so a will give
B maybe let's say it was $50 a month for
all of his things and B in response
gives a things and then B she buys all
of her things from C and she pays that
same amount she takes the full $50 that
she earned and she gets various things
that she needs in life from C and then
similarly C buys all of his things from
D and let's say just for simplicity that
it's the same amount and then D buys all
of her things from a and this is
obviously way oversimplified as an
economy but I do think it gives a good
feel for kind of the cyclic nature of
things that one person's income is
another person's expenses so now let's
say that you're in a hyperinflationary
circumstance where you have this you
know 80% increase per month something
that cost $100 one day a month later is
going to cost $180 if you were say
person a and you knew the prices of
things are going to increase you might
in anticipation raise your prices as
you're selling things to D you might
raise your prices and say well actually
today I think I'm going to charge you
fifty one dollars because things are
getting more expensive so I want to earn
more and then deed in response says geez
now I have to pay more so I'm going to
have to charge my customer C a little
bit more as well and I'm going to charge
him 51 and then C says I'm going to have
to charge my customer more as well in
order to make ends meet and everybody
kind of has to
increase their prices to keep up and
when the next day rolls around you know
no one wants to be the last one to
increase their prices so maybe this time
bee says Oh yesterday I had prices
increase on me and I was earning less
but then I had to spend more so today
I'm going to make sure that I'm not the
last one so I'm going to increase my
prices and I'm going to increase them
maybe she says 53 just to be sure and
then a noticing the prices have
increased has to keep up as well so he
needs to do this and of course the cycle
continues everyone in order to make ends
meet has to increase their prices so
this circumstance where you're changing
your prices in anticipation of future
change is what distinguishes
hyperinflation in kind of a qualitative
sense from regular inflation you know I
think there's a quote that I really like
I think it's by Napoleon and it's a
quantity sometimes has a quality all of
its own and that's definitely the case
with hyperinflation because ordinary
inflation ordinary inflation like let's
say that which the United States dollar
is undergoing around these days
typically ends up being around 1 to 3
percent it depends but 1 to 3 percent
per year so obviously this is
dramatically less than you know a
hundred thousand percent per year but
the idea is that hyperinflation isn't
just that it's a much bigger number it's
that there's a psychological difference
in the society where people are starting
to anticipate changes and change their
prices accordingly and this is how
things spiral out of control this is how
you get insane numbers like 80 percent
per month now why am I talking about
this right this is about functions of
money why am i talking about
hyperinflation well let's take a look at
these functions of money and kind of
analyze whether or not they still apply
in a hyper inflationary economy now
medium of exchange money is still being
used as a medium of exchange people are
still buying things using the national
currency so that one stays intact store
value however this one clearly breaks
down because if you're holding on let's
say you have a hundred dollars in
savings today and then you know that
things are increasing by a hundred
thousand percent per year it's going to
be 1,000 times less valuable after a
year so most certainly it is no longer a
store of value and you could argue by
the way that even in an ordinary
inflation circumstance money doesn't
quite serve this function as a store of
value because even if prices are
increasing only very slowly every year
it's still the case that you know a
dollar that you hold on to you know
you're not investing it or collecting
interest rate slowly degrades over time
so you
argue that even in an ordinary
circumstance store value doesn't quite
apply due to inflation but let's
consider this third this third function
of money unit of value if you're living
in this hyper inflationary circumstance
the numbers that you're seeing no longer
really correspond to value right if you
had something that originally was $50 of
value and then after a year it's $50,000
you're not thinking of the value of that
thing in terms of the national currency
and often throughout history people
start thinking of the value of various
items in terms of another nation's
currency so if your own currency all of
the numbers are fluctuating very rapidly
and they're increasing very rapidly you
look for a more stable number just so if
you want to know hey how much should a
carton of milk cost rather than thinking
in your own nation's currency maybe say
oh it's analogous to you know 1.5
British pounds or something that seems a
little bit more stable so this unit of
value property no longer applies in the
case of hyperinflation and notice that
that's distinct that is something
different between hyperinflation and
regular inflation because even in let's
say the United States these days even
though prices slowly increase we still
think about the value of things in terms
of the US dollar this still serves as
our our unit of value so that's one of
the core distinctions and I think that's
that's actually very important for you
know what distinguishes hyperinflation
from inflation in a qualitative sense
now why did I choose to think about
Brazil's hyperinflation as opposed to a
lot of other ones like post-world War
one Germany or is it Bob way or places
where you've had even faster rates of
hyperinflation and basically because
there was a really interesting way that
they went about solving it now any
solution has to address the underlying
causes of inflation and this video isn't
necessarily about those so there's going
to be things associated with making sure
that the government is still fiscally
responsible and balancing budgets and
things like that
but a different component that needs to
be addressed is that money is no longer
serving as a unit of value so one really
interesting thing that Brazil did in the
early 1990s is they introduced a fake
currency that they called the u rv4 unit
of real value or really it was in the
really it's the portuguese words for
these I think unidade of the Lord I
don't really know Portuguese but the
initials are the same you are V and what
they started doing is saying okay
everybody continue paying in the
national currency which
the time was the the crucero I'm
probably pronouncing that wrong but
Crusader oh so they're still paying for
everything in terms of their crucero
that's serving as the medium of exchange
but what they did is they said every
time that you're pricing something
please list your price is not only in
terms of the crucero so I guess in this
case I've written dollars but let's say
let's pretend that says 53 crucero 51
crucero things like that and in addition
to listing it there please also list the
price in terms of units of real value
which in this case might have been like
50 because everything started off being
50 and they loosely pegged this fake
currency that's just made-up number to
the US dollar so over time even though
the price in terms of cruzeiro's was
increasing it might be 53 cruzeiro's and
then 55 and everyone's paying more and
more in terms of cruzeiro's the unit of
real value would stay the same because
it had no reason to increase it's just a
made-up number that you're pegging on
things just to keep straight how
valuable things actually are so what
they're basically doing is they just
they said currency our current money is
not serving this function as a unit of
value so let's just make up a new thing
that does so at this time the crucero
was still serving the function as a
medium of exchange
you know nothing was really storing the
function of cert store value except for
hard goods like land and then this
made-up number was serving the function
as a unit of value and over time as
people started getting used to the idea
that you go out to buy milk and you you
know that it's going to be lets say one
unit of real value and then you just
have to look up okay how many how many
cruzeiro's corresponds to a unit of real
value today people start actually
thinking in terms of this number even
though they're paying in terms of
another and after this had kind of said
into the psychology of the society and
of course while certain certain fiscal
responsibilities on the side of the
government was being addressed they made
the switch to make units of real value
and actual currency and printing money
in terms of these you RVs and abandoning
the crucero and telling people they
could trade in their crucero for these
you RVs and that was going to be the new
currency and because people were used to
the idea that this was a stable number
and they were thinking of prices in
terms of this stable number and because
the the underlying causes of inflation
had started to be addressed it actually
worked and the number would stay stable
and instead of having prices increase
eighty percent a month it decreased
drastically to something that's much
closer
for two you know a healthy economies
level of inflation and I think that's
really powerful actually that that you
can recognize that one of the functions
of money has broken down and then
address it specifically and you know
invent something new that addresses that
same function sure it's a made-up
currency it's just a number you're
assigning things but it's serving this
function and then apply that in a very
real setting on the scale of an entire
nation and solve an economic problem
so hopefully this sheds a little bit of
light on why it might be useful to break
down the functions of money in terms of
these three different categories and
with that I will see you next video